why would an active reprise of all many
called his biggest failure and there's a
surprise cameo in the flash a hint of
things to come morning spoilers for The
Flash just ahead what many thought would
be the last gasp of Zack Snyder's era as
Warner Brothers DC film division may
have planted the biggest CDF for the
regime set to replace her at the end of
Andy muskete's The Flash Barry Allen
manages to revert his time ravaged
Universe back to the way it was at the
beginning of the story with one major
exception he's stuck with the wrong
Batman after appearing in the original
timeline as Ben Affleck and later as
Batman 89 star Michael Keaton Bruce
Wayne ultimately takes the shape of none
other than George Clooney
huh
first you're going to tell me where it
freeze is and then you're going to jail
the Hollywood icon starts in such
beloved projects as ER Gravity Oh
Brother Where Art Thou and up in the air
evolving from a small screen stalwarts
into one of the most bankable Leading
Men in the film industry despite the
fact that he made what some would call a
career misstep by starring in the
critically maligned 1997 film Batman and
Robin remembered for its cheesy lines of
dialogue and an icy turn from Arnold
Schwarzenegger as Mr Freeze Batman and
Robin is regarded as one of the worst
comic book films made if the flash is
attempting to be abrased to the new DC
continuity this stage is seemingly set
for Clooney's take on Batman to make a
comeback in a big way well Matt Reeves
builds his own gritty grounded franchise
around the Batman's Robert Pattinson DC
film CEO James gern as promised yet
another take on the Caped Crusader
George Clooney's return as Bruce Wayne
in James Gunn's DC Universe is
surprising to say the least not only is
Batman and Robin a critical failure in
and of itself it thwarted any potential
to Tim Burton and Joel Schumacher era of
Batman films like going forward it's
mediocre box office performance combined
with its terrible critical reception
almost brought down the superhero genre
as a whole
[Music]
I freeze I'm Batman
even Clooney has acknowledged how poorly
Batman and Robin turned out calling the
film a waste of money and apologizing
for taking the role merely because he
thought it would help his career for him
to return to the character that earns
him his third worst Rotten Tomatoes
score is almost staggering especially
since he just took a multi-year break
from performing in the wake of a series
of commercial bombs considering this it
almost seems equal parts poetic and
unlikely that Clooney now 62 years old
would jumpstart the next Act of his
career with the character that almost
killed it years ago but all that being
true he could be the perfect choice for
James gunns to Brave in The Bard
good night back when James Gunn first
revealed his plans for a Batman movie
titled the Brave and the Bold he stated
that it would focus on the Dark Knight
struggles with fatherhood and his
relationship with his estranged son
Damien Wayne in the comics Damien is a
child of Bruce Wayne and Talia al Ghul
well Michael Keaton's Batman seems a bit
too wild to be a believable father and
Ben afflecks is too buried in the
remnants of so much unfulfilled side of
her's law George Clooney's Batman is all
that once a proven commodity and a blank
slate despite having a clear image of
how the actor might portray Gotham's
notorious vigilante no one knows enough
about his cinematic backstory for there
to be rigid narrative constraints looks
like it's going to be a beautiful day
that seems like the thoughts of selling
point that might see a compromise
between Warner's and the eagerly
inventive gun while returning to the bat
cave may be a curious career move for
Clooney in 2023 it also might be the
most sensible and exciting choice for
the future of the Batman franchise all
this being said much of this is
speculation as Gunners famously kept his
DC ideas Under Wraps even with Clooney's
appearance in the flash it just seems
out of character for the director to
make such an announcement to a cameo in
a movie he neither produced nor directed
in any case the flash has fans over the
moon about future Batman films
foreign